there's a slice some wonderful hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to three scary games now
I'm not gonna do a gimmick this time
around in the beginning I'm gonna get
right into the game nothing bad is gonna
happen see nothing bad okay so this
first game is called the skeleton in the
park of nightmares it's cute it's
adorable
and it seems to have a kind of a minke
in the bed machine kind of thing going
on here so we're gonna find my dad was
fish though oh oh
I don't remember walking through that
skeletons are you why are you on the
roof why are you on to earth you take it
over to earth so are you doing okay
alright skeletal and I don't like that
you have a dick oh no that's that that's
your hip bones connected to the dick
bone why is there pull Oh gross alright
sure this looks cool I like the style
they misspelled Park but I think that's
okay don't judge them too much on that
hello oh do tell ye I don't know hello
can I open anything probably not you're
you are oh no poor k okay okay maybe no
okay Oh
[Music]
oh sorry I didn't know that I was
supposed to be scared by that kind of
caught me off guard a little bit there
that's the others gonna go I see what's
that oh wow I can't look up exactly so I
kind of just got to keep my head down to
eyes at the ground pretend nothing Bad's
happening okay Oh interesting
I'm okay with this it's good let's go
over to food land
Wooper to certain all food land don't
look so fun oh oh you know it does have
kind of a charm to it it obviously
doesn't have much of a Polish to it but
this game does seem to have a bit of a
charm is that the thing why the wombly
sure that look oh okay there we go I can
jump I can't look up woah woah what I
just did it's awfully wet now and loud
it's loudly wet all right who's gonna
pretend like Oh what no oh okay
alright goodbye I guess I'll go to
desert land with this rushing water
through my head the LA mine huh oh no la
mine I think that's what that is
hello oh [ __ ] oh I can look up now why
can't I look up now I couldn't look up
before OOP not gonna catch me I'm sorry
I'm gonna ignore all the do not enter
signs just barge my way and okay
whoa-oh-oh-oh who's too busy looking at
the big old thing in the okay never mind
alright I guess there's something going
on here
I see uh-huh
do tell go on can I pick this up nope
alright didn't need it anyway that was
why I like the paintings on the walls I
think that just might be the musical
scooper I don't think anything actually
happening I think that's just the music
playing so I'm gonna go on as if nothing
bad is happening to me nothing bad is
okay makes sense good great oh no I
can't break through that oh wow what the
[ __ ] hi hello how are you
how we doing okay goodbye Oh
see ya where'd you go well there you are
Oh No
all right whatever you say oh did I say
something snarky in French can I get
someone in the comments to please
translate that for me thank you very
much
all right I guess I'll alright well
that's two down of whatever the hell I'm
trying to do I was still not 100% clear
on what my objective is I guess I got to
go in there Mort is that Mort Mort what
does that mean more death dead Mort Mort
Mort alright what did I just say
it's Suez then open now oh it's open
okay oh and now I can look up oh great
great that's very confusing to hold not
being able to are whatever I'm going
into the morgue
this is definitely this is definitely
site of some like bendy in the a machine
love story right it's like a Loveland
who shouldn't have done that I can't
quite jump in there
oh yeah that's normal oh that's that's a
slice of something normal oh boy
why am i running towards the giant baby
head oh hey giant baby hey you better
not talk to me okay you better not say
nothing to me oh I love this game I love
is great it's wonderful it's wonderful
this slice some wonderful okay oh the
light oh I died when I was eight years
old [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
now listen here all right that was not
bad not bad
it was stylized I liked that it was
obviously made by someone who would
didn't have a lot of technical skills in
making games but the fundamentals were
there like the movement was janky the
environment was weirdly placed the
pacing was off but it worked and it had
style and it had a few scares that kind
of made me jump which is pretty good so
I give it an A for effort and a B for
execution and a C for overall polish so
bad that up and whatever the average
score is that's what that is
that was pretty good I hope the
developer keeps going because that has
some potential
okay so shifting gears a little bit this
one is called the wind apparently this
is a game based on a short or indie film
that's coming out or has come out and it
is stylized in like old-school dos level
graphics it is way way way old-school Oh
[Music]
Who am I playing holy [ __ ] the laundry
got blown away you want to run that by
me again
it's like old Oregon Trail level stuff
okay Lizzy is alive Isaac is away emma
is dead Gideon is away so Lizzie is
alone Oh Oh God Oh oh this reminds me of
like the Phenom in II games oh [ __ ] okay
Oh
oh good yeah oh [ __ ] [ __ ] no wolf
defective nah holy [ __ ] okay get the gun
get the gun oh oh [ __ ] I'm out of
bullets oh [ __ ] the bullet I kill him I
kill them all oh my god okay
this game's no joke lights coming from
Emma and Gideon's Oh what Emma is dead
isn't Emma dad I thought Emma was dead
oh no oh no oh boy okay oh that's not
good stiffy step beyond that oh hi hello
s tree okay hi hello it's weird how this
is creeping me out like this
this was Emma's oh good Emma's demon
Bible where's your gun Oh Oh Jase dog
hello hello okay I'm good
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh how is this game
creepy the preacher comes to visit oh
good oh great I don't like you I don't
like you at all
I don't like your grabby uh Mara taker
of souls no no no you don't come oh [ __ ]
Oh taker of souls
what there's something here I'm gonna go
over to Amman Gideon's house but see
what's up over there hello
no one all right well this is a waste of
time okay I'll follow you where'd you go
where'd you go where'd you go where did
you go
why is this deep steering me how is this
bloody oh babe
wait but maybe if I had shot it oh [ __ ]
I don't think there was a chance okay
that was shockingly good I am stunned at
how good that was
I am stunned that was great I loved that
that was flippin great I don't have
anything else to say it just goes to
show you don't need great graphics to
make a horror experience like that was
creepy it was creepy for all the right
reasons and had great execution and
great style the music was fitting to the
theme it all worked like if the
imagination is doing all the work you
don't need to have something amazing to
pull off scares like that's really cool
anyway what does this get stuffed it is
recommended to play with the lights off
and your volume up okay see I didn't
actually read that because I was trying
to listen oh my god
Oh avoid disappointment by giving up oh
good advice uh-huh oh this is weird
mobility collect mobile from security
office downstairs okay oh man
yet I'm the problem mr. Andrews left his
music on again okay okay I'm going to
security downstairs where I'm I'm sorry
that's probably nothing probably a whole
lot of nothing oh that opened I don't
know where my mobile would be or if I'm
supposed to go over here in the first
place no this is probably where I run
away screaming like a little [ __ ] baby
so I'm not gonna go here right away
oh never mind never mind I guess I'm
stuck uh-huh uh-huh Oh oh that's much
easier okay glacial huh must be another
game that they
oh wait wait wait wait okay hang on a
second I you know I've had a lot of
hallucinations in my time and various
games that I've played never have I seen
a big bulbous man appear directly in
front of me because that's really
freaking weird where's my mobile
can I have my mobile there's my mobile I
got my mobile oh hi sir now that I got
that what do I do with myself in my life
do I do anything can't leave without my
stuff bags should be hanging by the
lockers I know where the lockers are
from the staff room upstairs okay sure
yeah staff room upstairs how far
upstairs all the way upstairs that's a
weird place to have a staff room makes
you really inconvenient for everybody
coming into this place hello
a drone yeah okay all right that makes
sense hello why are there lockers all
the way back here it always seems
impossible and it is give up oh okay all
right good for me then all right oh is
that my bag oh oh hi
yeah that's normal hi how are you doing
my name is mo a gun perfect I'll take
that thank you can I have a hug that gun
that's oh ah hello goodbye okay great
let me just tell you I am very happy
that I'm here I'm just gonna just the
emergency lights no fret oh yeah
just the emergency lights and definitely
nothing else oh hi the car keys aren't
even in this bag forgot Anders borrow
the car for lunch yeah this is normal la
dee dee dee dah dee dah
I am fine I am very fine okay oh ha all
righty then that's normal that's very
normal all of this oh hi oh Jesus
Wow alright see you then
good god fine who am lost Oh [ __ ]
criminy
oh hi hello Stacey oh yeah oh oh hi yeah
perky's where now where did I put now
where did I put my car keys car keys
sorry about the invasive search straight
to the car and driving the hell away
from here you know what that's the
wisest thing you've said thus far at
least this guy is like cool in the face
of danger oh I can zoom I didn't know
that all right everybody have a good day
hold my calls hold my calls
oh I'll be back in on Monday late mo
late Monday my flight comes in how tired
am i oh wow
alright see ya see you guys around
oh man hump day am i right oh wow am i
working hard or hardly working
hey how you doing hey how you doing you
know we're out of this hellhole
you know why oh you shouldn't have
Oh give me a hug hug nice boobs okay ah
there we are
man this is really running like a turd
now the frame rate is really tanked but
that's okay hello goodbye sorry had
beans for lunch hey how you doing excuse
me pardon me okay cool
this is a slice of something special hi
let's assume I'm still asleep in my
office and this is one weird nightmare
yeah man
you are too calm in the face of what's
happening right now
you are way to come all right well I
looked around there
[Music]
not bad but what a trippy adventure what
a weird adventure what a strange bizarre
turn of events um yeah not not bad not
bad at all so that was three scary games
just thank you everybody so much forgot
other scare games you want me to play
put them down in the comments below and
check out the other scare games that I
played in the past oh and if you haven't
checked out cloak and you want some
comfy clothes for yourself go to cloak
brand calm check out some cool stuff
I'll put a link in the description it's
uh clothes made for you delicious
delectable comfy clothes check them out
and thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]